[Musique]
merci t Verrien d'être avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
de Lyonne memb du groupe Union centriste
et vous présidez ici au Sénat la
délégation au droits des femmes à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes on va parler dans quelques
instants de votre audition hier d'Éric
dupontetti mais d'abord l'actualité on
l'a vu c'est toujours cette colère
agricole les annonce du Premier ministre
on va y venir et la FNSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs et la coordination qui
appelle à suspendre les blocages est-ce
que Gabriel Atal a réussi à gérer cette
crise agricole je pense qu'il l'a bien
géré maintenant c'est ce que disait
l'agricultrice qu'on vient d'entendre et
ce que me disent
également ce que me disait également le
président de la FDSEA de Lyonne c'est on
est content des paroles que nous avons
entendu maintenant nous attendons des
écrits pour être sûr que ça ne s'envole
pas et que ça se transforme en acte
ensuite donc voilà mais je pense qu'il a
effectivement plutôt bien géré la chose
est-ce que ces ces annonces elles
répondent en grande partie à la colère
des agriculteurs c'est ce que dit
matigon oui parce que de toute façon euh
les annonces qui ont été faites
répondent à des questions mais qui se
posent depuis des années euh la
concurrence déloyales euh par rapport à
certains insecticides je pense en partie
par exemple des cerizes nous dans nous
sommes producteurs de Ceriz euh
l'insecticide qui traitait les cerizes
nous a été interdit mais en Espagne on
l'utilise en Pologne on l'utilise donc
c'est même pas par rapport au marché
extraeuropéen c'est au sein même de
l'Europe
et donc c'est le problème des
surtranspositions et je pense que c'est
ce qu'ils attendent le Gabriel Atal a
promis plus de surtransposition ça c'est
une chose mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
celles qui ont déjà eu lieu et qui
bloquent aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui
il est vrai que quand il y a une
surtransposition c'est pour aller vers
plus de santé pour pour nous y compris
pour les agriculteurs mais à condition
de pas importer des produits qui ont été
traités avec ces produits là dans ces
cas-là puisque si ça met en danger notre
santé bah ça le met y compris quand
c'est produit en Pologne ou en Espagne
ouais alors il a interdit euh il a dit
qu'il voulait interdire l'importation de
certains produits traités avec des
pesticides notamment en Italie et en
Espagne il a aussi dit qu'il y aurait
plus d'interdiction de pesticides en
France si ces pesticides étaient
autorisés dans le reste de l'Union
européenne et il a également suspendu le
plan écopyo est-ce qu'il a sacrifieré
l'écologie au profit de l'agriculture
alors pour l'instant je pense qu'il a
calmé calmé le jeu et ensuite je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une étude fine
parce que il est vrai que à la fois
quand on écoute les agriculteurs et y
compris sur mon territoire euh on voit
que leur pratique visent vraiment à
baisser l'utilisation des
phytosanitaires on voit de plus en plus
même si aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus
dur d'être en bio parce que les prix ne
sont pas en face mais de plus en plus de
de transformation vers du bio je sais
que l'enseignement agricole qui est
prodigué dans Lyonne fait une belle part
aussi au bio et parallèlement on a
l'impression que les phytosanitaires ne
baissent pas donc il faut essayer de
d'avoir une analyse plus Chine de savoir
d'où ils viennent où ils vont qui les
utilise vraiment pour attaquer ceux qui
sont réellement concernés et pas tout le
monde alors le gouvernement a été aussi
très fermière avec la grande
distribution pardon en plus des
contrôles et des sanctions qui étaient
déjà annoncé pour ceux qui ne respectent
pas la loi égalim Bruno Le Maire a
annoncé des contrôles sur le fait que
les produits qui se disent français et
qui s'affichent comme tel le soit
réellement et il dit si ce n'est pas le
cas il y aura des amendes allant jusqu'à
10 % du chiffre d'affaires il fallait
frapper un grand coup avec la grande
distribution évidemment pu que la loi
égalime est une bonne chose mais comme
pour toute politique publique si on
l'applique pas et si on n pas de
contrôle ni de sanction quand on
l'applique pas et ben du coup c'est la
liberté en fait à ceux qui ne souhaitent
pas obéir et objectivement notre grande
distribution a dès le départ refusé la
loi égalime et fait un bras de fer et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a eu Galim 1
égalim 2 et maintenant le principe c'est
pas forcément égalimme 3 c'est un
égalimme 2 qui soit respecté réellement
alors il y a les choses ce qu'on peut
faire sur le plan national et puis aussi
il y a beaucoup de choses qui dépendent
de l'Union européenne de Bruxelles
est-ce que comme la FNSEA vous diriez
qu'il y a une surdité de l'Europe à ces
revendications des agriculteurs le
problème de l'Europe c'est tous les
mouvements qui s'y déroulent et et
surtout des des ceux qui sont élus et on
voit bien que effectivement c'est pas
forcément une surdité de l'Europe mais
ceux qui siège ne sont pas forcément
ceux qui défendrai notre système
agricole ouais Emmanuel Macron qui a
également annoncé des des demandes en
tout cas il a fait des demandes à
l'Europe sur un égalisme Européen sur
des contrôles européens est-ce que ça va
dans le sens de ce que vous dites
c'est-à-dire on peut pas avoir en France
des choses qui ne sont pas respectées
dans les autres pays de l'Union
européenne évidemment et en 2019 l'UDI
avait une liste aux Européennes on a
Paris fou euh et mais pour autant
c'était dans nos propositions en 2019
déjà nous le disions que ça n'était pas
possible de produire de de d'interdire
en France des choses qu'on ninterdit pas
ailleurs et donc il fallait vra vraiment
une vraie politique européenne et que
les règles soient les mêmes pour tous
pour qu'il ait pas une concurrence comme
ça inter on a déjà une concurrence au
niveau social si en plus on remet une
concurrence au niveau des produits qu'on
peut utiliser c'était vraiment trop cher
payer pour nos agriculteurs nous le
disions bon on n pas vraiment été
entendu vous l'aurez remarqué non juste
une petite parenthèse sur ce que vous
dites vous dites c'était un Paris fou
d'avoir une liste européennes ça veut
dire qu'il faut pas refaire ce Paris là
bah ça veut dire que on y réfléchit mais
c'est si c'est pour les mêmes chances de
succès c'est vrai que c'est un petit
dommage donc Plô aller avec la majorité
présidentielle je ne sais pas pour le
coup le choix n'est pas fait franchement
bon allez on revient à l'agriculture on
va voir comment ça se passe dans votre
département de Lyonne on y va tout de
suite on va à Sens bonjour Mathieu
villeris de Galot merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes journaliste
responsable des agence à Lyonne
républicaine Mathieu comment ça se passe
ce matin du côté de Lyonne est-ce que la
tension baisse d'un cran
oui bonjour Rian bonjour Dominique
Verrien laatenstion baisse d'un cran
effectivement mais pour autant comme à
l'échelle nationale on voit VO bien que
il y a une certaine réserve il y a une
certaine prudence d'ailleurs nous avons
fait le choix de titrer ce matin sortie
de crise avec un point d'interrogation
et je crois que c'est le le reflet
effectivement de cette certaine prudence
des gens qui sont sur le terrain et qui
même sils ont annoncé que il faisaient
baisser la pression pour autant je
reprends ce que disait dominiic ver à
l'instant c'est sur les actes
effectivement qu'ils seront que le
gouvernement sera jugé sur cette crise
agricole vous avez une première question
pour Dominique veren Mathieu oui
j'écoutais effectivement vos vos
premières réponses de M Verrien à
l'instant et plus largement la réflexion
que je me posais c'était est-ce que
c'est pas le moment d'un changement de
modèle par rapport à à l'agriculture
française et est-ce que ce changement de
modèle vous vous paraît possible est-ce
qu'on va sortir du dogme défendu
notamment par la FNSEA depuis je crois à
peu près 80 ans d'une agriculture
française basée exclusivement sur le sur
la notion de production et qui est censé
contribuer à l'alimentation de 8
milliards d'habitants sur la planète
alors sur la production les agriculteurs
sont des entrepreneurs et donc il n'y a
aucune entreprise à qui on irait dire
écoutez vous êtes sympathique mais
maintenant on va vous demander d'essayer
de gagner votre vie sans produire ce que
vous vendez ce qui est quand même un
petit peu compliqué donc faut
aussi se dire que on peut pas demander
ça à une entreprise par contre le 8
milliards d'habitants peut-être que
notre mission à nous aujourd'hui n'est
plus forcément de se dire qu'on nourrit
8 milliards d'habitants par contre monre
qu'on aide les agriculteurs à vivre et
donc à vendre avec des vrais prix et
c'était un petit peu ça le principe de
la loi égalime donc il faut trouver cet
équilibre après le changement de modèle
en fait l'agriculture mais elle est en
train de changer de modèle mais depuis
plusieurs années et elle est obligée de
le faire d'ailleurs le changement
climatique li oblige donc le on voit
bien et elle s'adapte en permanence on
voit bien de il fut un temps il y a 10
ans il y avait des champs de colsa
partout dans Lyonne aujourd'hui ça a
énormément réduit on voit des filières
comme noise et noisettees de Bourgogne
si on Puisais c'est chez moi qui se
développe pour justement essayer d'avoir
de la transformation derrière les
Trophées de l'agriculture qui sont fait
avec l' lionne républicaine ont été
donné à des agriculteurs qui tous
quasiment avaient choisi de faire de la
transformation chez eux et pas forcément
d'ailleurs avec des grandes surfaces
mais avec d'une vraie valeur ajoutée du
produit qu'il créaent derrière donc elle
se transforme l'agriculture en
permanence elle c'est je pense que c'est
le métier qui s'est le plus transformé
sur les 20 dernières années donc on peut
pas dire c'est toujours le même système
parce que non et d'ailleurs quand on
regarde Lyonne ça ressemble pas
forcément à l'abri donc on peut pas non
plus tout réduire et pareil pour la
FNSEA on avait Martine Lambert alors
c'est vrai qu'on passe à Arnaud Rousseau
qui semble mieux répondre au modèle dont
vous parlez mais Martine Lambert était
quand même productrice bio et éleveuse
donc c'était Christian ou christici
présid deristian lbert l'ancien
président de la FNSEA donc je pense que
les agriculteurs son sont pas du tout
uniformes et et qu'ils ils s'acceptent
dans leur diversité je pense que notre
chambre d'agriculture fait un gros
travail justement sur ces changements de
pratique donc en fait cette
transformation elle a déjà lieu et je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'on la valorise
plus d'ailleurs pour pour mieux
communiquer une deuxième question Arnaud
euh Mathieu pardon voilà moi aussi
maintenant je moi aussi maintenant je
mélange sur la souveraineté alimentaire
exactement c'est le gouvernement vient
vient d'annoncer le l'importance de la
production agricole pour la souveraineté
alimentaire ça veut dire que c'est pour
vous la fin d'un plan social silencieux
qui a vu le nombre d'exploitation
agricoes à divisé par 4 en France depuis
un
demi-sècle alors j'avoue que je ne sais
pas je sais pas comment ça va ça va
évoluer mais si ça a divisé par 4 c'est
aussi parce qu'on a de la mécanisation
et qu'on a pas besoin d'avoir autant de
personnes pour s'occuper d'une même
surface donc là-dessus par contre il est
vrai que euh au niveau de la
transformation je parlais de
l'enseignement agricole aujourd'hui au
lycée la brosse qui est un lycée
agricole bien connu de notre département
la moitié je crois voir plus de la
moitié des élèves ne sont pas issus du
monde agricole donc on voit qu'il a
effectivement cette transformation qui
est en train de se faire et c'est vrai
pour aller plutôt vers du maréchage vers
des plus petites structures donc
peut-être qu'on va voir le nombre
d'agriculteurs remonter c'est un vrai
sujet moi qui m'occupe plus d'urbanisme
et de comment on gère la ville c'est un
sujet important parce que dans nos
villages une des raisons pour lesquelles
aussi on perd des habitants c'est que on
a perdu beaucoup d'agriculteurs alors on
les remplacera pas il faut qu'on les
remplace par autre chose mais justement
c'est cette idée de pouvoir transformer
sur place et d'avoir éventuellement des
petites unités de production qui
permettraient d'avoir du travail et de
faire vivre d'avoir la valeur ajoutée
chez nous et non pas à l'extérieur
pourrait être une bonne solution merci
mathieur villroit Galot on revoit la Une
de lionne républicaine vous vous le
disiez cette question a une sortie de
crise point d'interrogation c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Mathieu merci d'avoir été avec nous on
passe à l'actualité du Sénat Dominique
Verrien et hier vous avez auditionné le
garde des S du poretti sur notamment sur
les violences conjugales et la
constitutionnalisation d'IVG on va
regarder ce qu'il s'est dit pendant
cette audition avec Quentin
[Musique]
calm bonjour Quentin bonjour bonjour
dominiqueonjour Quentin et Quentin le
garde des saau était donc auditionné
hier par la délégation au droits des
femmes pridé par Dominique Verrien pour
évoquer notamment les avancées en
matière de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes voilà l'audition
d'hier était effectivement l'occasion de
faire le bilan de l'action de son
gouvernement dans le contexte d'une
recru d'escence en 2022 du nombre de
victimes de violence conjugale il est
venu présenter les premiers chiffres des
outils mis en place dans cette lutte les
forces de l'ordre sont intervenu plus de
10000 fois en 2023 en lien avec un
bracelet antiapprochement a dit hier
Éric Dupont Moretti écoutez le détail en
2023 3 euh le nombre de drames
évités grâce au bracelet
antiraapprochement a été multiplié par 3
passant de
3634 en 2022 à près de
10000500 interventions des forces de
l'ordre que je veux
évidemment remercier c'est autant de
femmes sauvées
d'enfant d'enfants sauvés voilà pour ce
qui est du bracelet entier rapprochement
autre innovation mis en place ces
dernières années ces téléphone grave
danger pour appeler les secours en cas
d'agression de son conjoint ils ont
permis d'éviter 2500 drames en 2022 a
dit Éric Dupont meretti grâce à 3500
téléphones distribués c'était 727
seulement en 2020 qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ces premiers chiffres de
milven c'était ça l'intérêt de cette
audition hier c'était de présenter
l'évolution l'utilisation de ces outils
et ça va dans le bon sens ça va dans le
bon sens ça veut dire que tout le monde
sait saisi du sujet c'est la justice qui
les attribue et la police qui intervient
ou ou la gendarmerie évidemment chez
nous mais donc oui c'est plutôt ça va
plutôt dans le bon sens c'est d'ailleurs
un des éléments on a parlé de plein
d'autres éléments mais lespaule vif vous
savez don auquel je je tiens donc qui
sont ces pôles où et la justice pénale
et la justice civile vont pouvoir enfin
se parler pour avoir des décisions
cohérentes sont en train de se mettre en
place partout en France en ce moment je
suis invitée dans plusieurs tribunaux
cours d'appel pour pouvoir voir ces
installations ses mises en place des
pôles vif et bah ça fait plaisir de voir
que tous les magistrat enfin beaucoup
beaucoup de magistrats se saisissent de
de ce sujet vif violence intrafamiliale
et vous avez fait un rapport avec une
une députée également vous avez rendu
l'année dernière voilà plan rouge vif
exactement c'est depuis je m'habille
toujours en r donc dans le plan rouge
vif est vraiment en train de se décliner
va continuer à se décliner avec
l'ordonnance d'éviction immédiate ou de
protection immédiate qui va arriver donc
on le voit et c'est pourquoi il était
intéressant d'écouter le garde des saut
alors on avait énormément de sujets à
tré mais parce que réellement il a pris
au sérieux notre travail et il est en
train de décliner nos propositions donc
bah voilà pour une fois qu'un rapport
est entendu et s'applique et en plus à
des résultats sur le terrain on ne peut
que s'en féliciter oui c'est c'est un
satisfait site que vous adressez au
garde d'ESS saau sur cette évolution de
la prise de conscience au plus aux
insens de l'État tout à fait et vous
l'aurez peut-être noté c'était même ins
satisfait si de la part de Laurence
Rossignol donc l'cien ministre
socialiste oui c'est dire que le travail
se fait vraiment alors on n'est pas au
bout du chemin on a malheureusement
encore des drames qui se déroulent et je
pense que j'aimerait qu'un jour on en
est plus mais on a un gros travail
encore à faire et pas forcément en
justice parce qu'en justice on voit bien
que on est dans le traitement de
l'action et pas dans la prévention et
donc làou mais mais justement parce que
le chiffre officiel du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour les féminicides de
l'année dernière c'est 94 féminicides
alors c'est un chiffre qui est encore
énorme mais qui quand même est en baisse
de 20 % par rapport à l'année précédente
et sur ces 94 féminicides il y en a 30
victimes qui étaient connues des
services de police est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il y a encore aujourd'hui des
failles énormes oui il y a encore des
failles énormes dans la dans la
formation euh on le voit bien puisque
souvent souvent la faille c'est c'est
une erreur et souvent à l'origine avec
une information que la police ou l'
armerie àveine à pas faire monter au
procureur ou un procureur qui n'aura pas
poursuivi je pense que aujourd'hui
justement ces formations qui sont pour
prodiguer à la fois aux policiers aux
gendarmes aux services sociaux ça je
suis pas sûr qu'elles se mettent encore
en place mais elles vont es vont se
mettre en place vont permettre d'éviter
ces erreurs et de faire que tous les cas
seront traités et donc on évitera les
drames qu'on pourrait éviter on névitera
pas ceux qui sont bah le premier coup
immédiatement un coup mortel mais tout
ceux qu'on connaissait c'est absolument
normal qu'on soit passé à côté bon il y
a des failles mais la police et la
justice avance on comprend dans dans ce
que dans ce que vous dites vous disez il
y a encore d'autres sujet au-delà de la
police et de la justice P parler de
l'éducation certaines de vos collègues
de la délégation au droits des femmes
ont parlit aussi de du problème de
logement lors de la séparation entre
deux conjoints ou encore de la lutte
contre l'alcoolisme qui est des angles
un des angles morts du gouvernement vous
le dites voilà il y a des angles morts
encore dans l'action à faire alors il y
a encore des angles morts et mais mais
les services ST saisist alors comme
c'est vrai que en dans Lyonne par
exemple on a vraiment cette politique de
lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales au cœur le préfet a
décideré de aussi se joindre aux efforts
et de la gendarmerie de la police et de
la magistrature en luttant lui contre
les addictions parce que effectivement
on voit bien que les passages à l'acte
alors ça empêche pas euh une certaine
violence qui là se traiterait plutôt au
niveau de la prévention mais si on peut
éviter des passages à l'acte réellement
violents et ça on voit que l'alcool ou
la drogue d'une façon générale font des
ravages et donc oui oui il faut vraiment
lutter contre les addictions autre sujet
abordé hier par le garde saau il y a la
question de la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG et il faut dire Quentin que la
semaine qu'il vient de s'écrouler était
quand même cruciale sur ce sujet oui et
si tout s'était joué cette semaine
madame Verrien mardi soir on va revoir
des images les députés ont très
largement adopté un projet de loi du
gouvernement pour inscrire dans la
Constitution une liberté garantie pour
les femmes d'avoir recours à une
interruption volontaire de grossesse le
résultat du vote est sans ambiguité 493
voix pour contre 30 23 abstentions les
chefs de fil de la droite ont voté pour
comme Eric STI et lalr même chose pour
Marine Le Pen au rassemblement national
plus attendu toute la gauche et
Renaissance sont également voté pour
Orian et le sujet a donc été abordé hier
pendant l'audition d'Éric Dupont maréti
voilà c'est ce qui effectivement nous
amène à cette audition car c'est Éric
duporetti qui mène ce ce dossier au sein
du gouvernement enant que garde des
sauts il s'est montré très volontariste
dans le fait de faire aboutir rapidement
ce volet de la réforme de la
Constitution car maintenant que le texte
a été adopté par les députés il faut le
faire faireut le faire adopter par le
Sénat une chambre connu pour être plus
conservatrice écoutez donc Éric dupupont
Moretti hier je veux redire ici que nous
avons tout fait mais vraiment tout fait
pour que l'écriture proposée dans ce
projet de révision soit acceptée par une
majorité de sénate
et le gouvernement a pris je l'ai déjà
dit la quasi intégralité de l'écriture
du Sénat alors moi je dis tout
simplement faut pas rater ce moment il
faut pas rater cette alignement des
planètes un mot peut-être de réaction
Quentin oui vous partagez cette analyse
il y a une forme de volontarisme sur ce
dossier aussi tout à fait alors il est
vrai que le gouvernement a fait une
grave erreur en annonçant la date du
Congrès qui a profond anticipé le fait
que voilà le vote allait se faire au sén
c'est ça bah tout à fait puisque nous
nous allons débattre le 28 février et il
organise le Congrès le 4 mars
c'est-à-dire que ça veut dire qu'on n
pas considéré qu'il puisse y avoir
encore un aller-retour avec l'Assemblée
nationale et de mais même dans son
discours de politique générale mardi
devant les députés Gabriel Attal a dit
nous inscrirons l'IVG dans la
Constitution tout c'est des maladresses
pour vous c'est une vraie maladresse
puisque ça veut dire qu'on a plus notre
mot à dire donc c'est un peu et donc
c'est tentant de se dire que on peut
éventuellement faire capoter ce congrès
alors la la présidente de la délégation
au droits des femmes que je suis vous
imaginez bien préfère se dire je suis
sénatrice je suis vexé comme tous les
sénateurs je pense mais là il y a une
chose bien plus importante qui est de de
préserver de protéger le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps et je
pense que ça doit dominer tout le reste
et donc moi j'invite évidemment tous mes
collègues à voter cette
constitutionnalisation et je les invite
à aller voter
dans les termes de l'Assemblée nationale
de telle sorte que nous puissions
effectivement aller au Congrès et
ensuite passer à autre chose parce que
nous aurons fait quelque chose de normal
en France c'est protéger la liberté des
femmes de disposer de leur corps Quentin
c'est pas la vie de Gérard archet non
tout à fait effectivement il y a
quelques jours j'ai Larché le président
de l'institution s'est dit opposer à
faire rentrer cette IVG dans la
Constitution selon lui il ne faut pas
faire de la Constitution un catalogue
des droits sociaux et sociétaux autre
argument le droit à l'IVG n'est pas en
danger en France alors le garde des saut
encore une fois hier a répondu à cet
argument on écoute à nouveau
ercetti et les expériences
étrangères en la matière nous démontrent
que rien n'est acquis oui effectivement
donc éc Duti est pas du tout d'accord
avec Gérard Larcher il y a une pression
sur l'IVG en France vous le croyez alors
il y a une pression et vous allez voir
que je pense que les antichois comme on
les appelle puisque le principe c'est
que si une femme est enceinte elle doit
forcément avoir cet enfant voire même
puisqu'on parle du droit de l'enfant à
naître faudrait-il la pousser à avoir
cet enfance si c'est l'enfant qui
appelle comme ça désespérément on sait
pas où on sait pas d'où mais euh donc et
je pense qu'ils seront devant notre
notre chambre pour expliquer à quel
point ce serait une mauvaise chose que
de prés il y AA des manifestations
devant le Sénat vous le croyez à la fin
du mois de février je je veux bien que
nous parlions mais je je le crains parce
que c'est mouvements existent ces
mouvements sont financés ces mouvements
veillent justement à ce qu'on ne protège
pas ce droit ce droit qui recule partout
où ces mouvements conservateurs et
religieux prennent prennent le pouvoir
euh il s fait débat Quentin la dit au
sein de la majorité sénatoriale et donc
dans votre groupe on recevait votre
collègue sénateur centriste lï HERV
mercredi qui lui est opposé à cette
constitutionnalisation il nous disait
notamment que c'était pas une bonne
chose de laisser la main sur un tel
sujet au juge constitutionnel et qu'il
fallait mieux laisser la main au
Parlement est-ce que c'est un argument
que vous entendez non non parce que en
fait la modification de la Constitution
demande les 35e et justement c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles on se
demande si on va y arriver ou pas et
donc de la même façon pour le démonter
il faudra faire la même chose demain
vous avez une majorité qui est contre
l'IVG simplement parce que là on parle
pas de pour ou contre la
constitutionnalisation demain qui il
suffira d'avoir la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale il y aura même pas
besoin du Sénat puisque par qu'on le
sait bien si jamais le Sénat ne vote pas
de façon conforme l'Assemblée nationale
l'assemblée à le dernier mot une grande
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et
l'autorisation saute alors ce sera pas
l'autorisation ce sera juste les délais
qui seront tellement courts comme à
certains endroits aux États-Unis que de
toute façon il sera impossible d'y avoir
recours j'ai une dernière question pour
ce qui me concerne mais je disais c'est
une semaine qui était crucial ce vote
qu'on a vu les chiffres qu'on rappelait
493 pour contre seulement 30 ça vous a
surpris en un sens vous êtes d'accord
avec moi ça fait que maintenant le Sénat
va vraiment devoir se poser la question
très sérieusement face à un tel vote
massif des députés oui c'est pour ça que
je disais que face à cette contrariété
et cette indélicatesse du gouvernement
je pense qu'on doit prendre nos
responsabilités et être plus intelligent
queot très l des députés ça change la
donne oui enfin j'espère que ça change
la donne moi personnellement de toute
façon j'étais prête à voter je sais pas
si ça va faire changer la vie de nos
collègues mais mais je est-ce que juste
ça va se jouer dans la rédaction parce
que au début l'assemblée était pour un
droit le Sénat a ensuite voté pour une
liberté et là l'Assemblée nationale a
revoté pour l'expression liberté
garantie est-ce que ce qui fait un peu
tiquer les sénateurs qui avaient même
ceux qui avaiit voté la la version avec
juste liberté est-ce que si on enlève le
mot garantie ça vous ira quand même
alors le problème c'est que si on enlève
le mot garanti ça fera un aller-retour
objectivement je crois que le mot
garantie est important enfin et et
permettrait effectivement d'avoir ce
vote conforme et donc ce même élan de
l'ensemble des deux chambres ce qui
serait quand même symboliquement très
intéressant euh et et plaisant et euh le
Conseil d'État a rassuré enfin en tout
cas son avis devrait rassurer tous ceux
qui ont peur de voir le mot garantie
s'afficher comme si euh ce droit-là
serait plus fort que les autres et ça
n'est pas le cas le garde des saau l'a
expliqué également hier donc ce serait
quand même formidable qu'il y ait un
vrai élan des deux chambres l'ILR à
l'Assemblée nationale on fait ce chemin
j'espère que au Sénat ils le feront
également merci Dominique verien merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure merci
et à très bientôt puisquil y évidemment
d'autres sujets que vous traitez au
Sénat notamment la question des familles
monoparental on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler c'est à la fin du mois je crois
que vousz vos travaux remisepp on vous
réinvite à ce momentlà merci merci ver
d'avoir été avec merci Quentin